We now continue our discussion
of the model in which we obtain
several measurements of an
unknown random variable Theta
in the presence
of additive noise,
under the same
assumptions as before.
Theta and Wi are all
independent random variables.
And they're also normal.
We have seen that in this case,
the posterior distribution
of Theta is a
normal distribution,
and it takes this
particular form.
We found the mean of the
posterior distribution, which
is also the maximum posterior
probability estimate.
And it is given by
this expression.
Now that we have an estimate
in our hands, we can ask,
how good is this estimate?
And for this, we need an
appropriate performance
measure.
For estimation problems, a
reasonable performance measure
is to look at the mean
value of the squared error.
But given that we have
already obtained observations,
what we're interested in is the
conditional mean squared error.
This is the error
that's remaining
after we have seen
the observations.
Now, let us notice
something here.
If I tell you the value
of the observations,
then my estimator is
completely determined.
The estimator is
a random variable
that processes the data and
comes up with an estimate.
So although it is
a random variable,
once I tell you the value
of the observations,
the value of this
random variable
has been completely determined.
And so we can replace it with
its actual numerical value,
which is theta hat.
And it is given by
this expression.
Now remember also that theta
hat, the estimate that we're
using, is the mean of the
posterior distribution.
In this conditional
universe where
we have conditioned
on this information,
theta hat is the mean
of this random variable.
So we're dealing with the
square distance from the mean.
And then we take
the expected value.
But that's nothing
but the variance
of Theta in this
conditional universe.
So what we're looking for is
the variance of the posterior
distribution of Theta,
given the observations
that we have obtained.
Can we eyeball the
variance by just
looking at this formula for
the posterior distribution?
More or less, we can.
Recall this earlier
fact that if I give you
a density of this form, you
recognize that it is normal.
And you also recognize
that the variance
is determined by
the coefficient that
comes next to a term
of the form x squared.
Now, this is a PDF
involving a variable x.
Here, we are talking
about a PDF of Theta.
So what we're looking
for is the constant
that sits next to the
theta squared term.
There's going to be multiple
theta squared terms.
So we need to
collect all of them.
And so we find that the overall
coefficient sitting next
to theta squared
terms is as follows.
From this, we obtain
a contribution
of 1 over 2 sigma 0 squared.
And similarly from
here, we're going
to obtain a coefficient
next to theta
squared of 1 over
2 sigma 1 squared.
We continue the same way.
And finally from
the last term, we
obtain a contribution
of this kind.
Now, we take this factor of
2, move it to the other side.
So we know what
2 times alpha is.
And then we need to take
the inverse of that,
so as to obtain 1 over 2 alpha.
And what we obtain is
that 1 over 2 alpha, when
alpha is given by
this expression,
is equal to this
expression here.
And so we have found the
conditional variance,
the variance of the posterior
distribution of Theta given
the data that we have
available in our hands.
Now, this is the
mean squared error
given that you have seen
some particular piece
of information.
What about the overall
mean squared error?
This is the quantity
that you care about
before you go and make
the actual measurements.
This tells you how
well you expect
to estimate your
random variable Theta.
Well, we can use here the
total expectation theorem,
and write the expected
value as a weighted average
of the conditional expectations
under different scenarios,
namely under different
measurements of X,
and average those
conditional expectations
over the possible values of X.
Now, this quantity here
is actually a constant.
It is this constant here.
So we can pull it
outside the expectation.
What we're left is
the integral of a PDF
over all possible values,
which has to be equal to 1.
So what we're left
with is just the value
of this constant, which
is this particular number.
And so we concluded that the
overall unconditional mean
squared error is also the same.
This makes perfect
intuitive sense.
Our mean squared error is going
to take this value no matter
what I observe.
So on the average, it will also
take that particular value.
Now, this expression
that we have derived
is also quite intuitive
in its content.
Let us try to understand
some special cases.
Suppose that some of the
variances of the noise terms
is very small.
If one term is small, this means
that the corresponding term
here is going to be big.
So the sum of those
terms is going to be big.
As long as one term is big,
than the sum is also big.
And then 1 over that
is going to be small.
So in that case, the mean
squared error is small.
What this is saying is that if
just one of the measurements
has low noise, then
the uncertainty that
remains for my random variable
that I'm trying to estimate,
that uncertainty will be small.
I'm going to have a small error.
On the other hand, if all of
the noise variances are large,
then this means that
all of these terms
here are going to be small.
I'm adding small terms.
1 over something small
is something big.
And so the mean squared
error is going to be large.
That is, if all my
measurements are very noisy,
then I do not expect to estimate
my random variable particularly
well.
Let us now look at
one more special case.
Suppose that all
of the variances
are the same, the noise
variances as well as
the variance of the
prior distribution.
In that case, this expression
here is going to become 1 over,
we have the sum
of n plus 1 terms.
And each one of those terms
is 1 over sigma squared, which
is the same as sigma
squared over n plus 1.
This expression makes
quite a lot of sense.
It tells us that if we obtain
more and more observations,
that is, as n increases,
we improve our performance.
The variance of the
posterior distribution,
or the mean squared error, goes
down in this particular way.
Now, perhaps the most
interesting aspect
of the facts that
we have established
is this equation
here that tells us
that not matter what
this value of little x
is, the conditional variance,
the variance of the posterior
distribution of Theta,
is going to be the same.
In some sense, it tells us
that no particular value of X
is more informative or more
desirable than any other value.
In order to really appreciate
what that statement is really
saying, it's better to look
at a very concrete example.
So let us revisit the
very first example
that we studied, in which case,
we only have one observation
and where Theta and W are
standard normal random
variables.
We did go through that example.
And we found that the
estimator, the maximum posterior
probability estimator, was
1/2 of the observation.
And now we are in a
position to also calculate
the conditional mean
squared error given
any particular observation.
We apply this formula.
In fact, we are dealing
with this special case
with sigma equal to 1.
So we use this expression here.
And we see that it is 1/2.
So we started with
a prior variance
for Theta, which was 1.
And after we obtained
the observation,
our uncertainty gets reduced and
the variance goes down to 1/2.
And this is true no
matter what little x is.
Pictorially, here
is what's happening.
We start with Theta
being a standard normal.
So it has a distribution of
this form, centered at 0.
This is a plot of the density
of Theta, the prior density.
Suppose that we
obtain a measurement.
And that measurement
happens to be equal to 0.
If the measurement
is equal to 0,
then our estimate will
also be equal to 0.
The posterior
distribution of theta
is going to be a normal
distribution whose mean is
the estimate and whose variance
is this quantity that we
have calculated, which is 1/2.
And therefore, it is narrower
than the original PDF
that we started from.
So initially, we had a
fair amount of uncertainty
about Theta.
After we obtained
a measurement of 0,
this kind of
reinforces our belief
that Theta is somewhere near 0.
And so we obtain a
narrower distribution.
This is our updated
belief about Theta.
But what if I happen to
obtain a measurement that's
somewhere out here?
In this case, my
estimate is going
to be 1/2 of what I observed.
It's here.
And the posterior
PDF of Theta is
going to be a normal PDF that's
centered around this point
and has the same variance, 1/2.
So in some sense, this
particular measurement
would be thought of as
a quite abnormal one.
We're really surprised to
obtain an observation which
is so far away from 0.
Because our prior
distribution told us
that Theta is somewhere here.
So we have been surprised.
But after the surprise and after
we form our estimate of Theta,
our state of
knowledge about Theta
is that Theta is
a random variable
and it has a distribution
that's normal,
centered around this
point, and whose width
is the same no matter what
particular observation I happen
to get.
So even though this particular
observation value is unusual,
after it is obtained,
the remaining uncertainty
about Theta is the same
as if we had obtained
any other particular
value of X. So this
is a very remarkable
property that's
special to this type of
estimation problems involving
normal random variables
and linear relations.
It has a very nice side effect.
It means that we
can report, we can
say anything there is to be
said about the performance
of this maximum a posteriori
probability estimator.
By just giving a
single number, we
can characterize
performance only
in terms of this
number, as opposed
to having to tell what this
conditional mean squared
error is for the
different values of X.